good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
thursday hope everyone is having an
amazing bright
and really inner peaceful day that's all
i can wish for you
that's all anyone can hope for this week
strangely sped on by like
when it was tuesday i was like it's only
tuesday but now it's thursday and
that's a great feeling i have just like
excitement about what lies ahead because
you know tomorrow for the first time in
literally eight months we're getting
botox
yes which is just i can't wait to not
move my face bye to this forehead
[ __ ]
and i think i'm also gonna get some lips
ooh i love when you do your lips
you know i sometimes like you go
shopping you go for one thing and then
you like leave with the whole store
i think i'm going to leave with dr
gizi's whole office like i just want all
of her new
and interesting procedures that's so
interesting okay now that you mentioned
like we're just shopping around i think
i'm gonna do some like stuff on the
tummy like the m sculpt that she has or
insta lipo
i just feel like you know i'm beyond
help from a machine
yeah right the only thing that can save
me is god right now today like i wish i
had gone like a few months ago when you
know i might have seen the difference
but i've just i've got some work to do
in the stomach department right now i
just love plastic and it's like and it's
not the kind that like someone could do
for me like i need to like
get to the gym i just love not even i
was gonna say the pedal time but like i
can't the peloton my stomach just sits
there
that's my issue with spinning like my
stomach just hangs
there while my legs are working so hard
i just love plastic surgery like
i feel like i go i go in phases where
i'm like it's toxic or like you know
it's bad for my
self-esteem but like right now i'm just
like so excited about waking up on
saturday with like a new face
yeah i'm excited about that too it's
interesting that you bring up plastic
surgery because i'm watching love island
right now and like
the people specifically the women have
like perfect bodies like
absolutely perfect like not can't relate
not a flab
out of place you can't relate on
anything and they all have big fake
titties
and i love a bft yeah i love a bft but
like it's just so
crazy to watch it's just like really
bodies like
perfect bodies with perfect titties and
it's like i don't know
it's also sort of like made me
appreciate my own titties because like
these girls are like
rocks right you know and sometimes you
just want to tuck them away no sometimes
it's like
i just it people are so different and
you know perspective is everything
because like
there are people who just like want big
titties
and then when you have big titties
naturally i feel like you nine times out
of ten like you hate them like
yeah and i cannot wait to like be done
having children and done breastfeeding
so i can get a reduction to literally a
double a i want to wear a trainer bra
and i want to get a reduction and a lift
like it's just it's funny how boobs are
like
universal and like everyone has their
own there's no like one beautiful boob
you know
yeah definitely it's just been
interesting but i also find that it's so
like i don't think that there's a
natural breast on that show and and i've
been noticing it more and more
when i shop online too like every single
model in the photos with the clothes has
fake titties and that doesn't like tell
me anything about how it's gonna look on
me that's so true you know what i mean
it's so true because we need like titty
diversity like it's
it's tough it's tough and you know what
like i feel like
nine times out of ten when i'm shopping
and i like a shirt like i don't get it
because of how it fits on my tits
yeah and because like i don't even
bother like when i
like because i just can't relate i
cannot relate no i agree like we need
some natural titties to
make a comeback yeah and and i love the
big fake titties and it's like so
enjoyable to watch i'm just it just like
has me in my thoughts
yeah about your own titties yeah so
something to think about but i agree i
love plastic surgery i'm
so excited to get this forehead in check
and it's also the holidays this weekend
so it's just gonna be like a nice
relaxing
weekend filled with like family and food
which is like pretty much been my
weekend like every weekend for the last
six months but i'm excited yeah i'm
really excited for rosh hashanah um
though it does start the countdown to
the ykb we are
is it next weekend yom kippur it's in
the middle of the week at least that
means like we got a day off
okay i am so dreading yom kippur
like it's been way heavy on my mind it's
been weighing really heavy
it's going to be a rough one i'm like
actually i should eat a lot this weekend
yeah in anticipation actually you
shouldn't like the sign says that that
stretches out your stomach and then
you'll actually be
if you could make your stomach a little
smaller you might be less hungry
i think you'll be hungry either way no i
think whatever you want my stomach is
definitely already stretched out i don't
think i have to worry about that
um but we have a fabulous show for you
guys today so much to discuss the fun we
have a fabulous show
as usual but something is very
unfabulous about today
oh yeah sorry theo the absence it's
literally like emma roberts unfabulous
yeah his absence is glaring he had a
business because you want to share
his statement that he prepared about why
he didn't show up to work he said
auntie you're getting really clingy and
it's proven to be too much for me i can
no longer handle it
so i will only be coming into the office
once a week from now on i know
like based on the way that he wrote that
that you were over his shoulder
telling him what to write because i know
that he would never say that to me
do you see us yesterday two peas in a
pod no totally it just me and ben got a
late start so he was still walking
while i had to leave so like i just
couldn't wait for him his schedule was
like running
back yeah okay um also i just think it's
worth noting that today is my three year
wedding anniversary
muzzle toe and like all my friends have
been like sending me like pictures and
videos for my wedding and my friend abe
sent me the funniest video of like me
and ben on the chair which
if you've never been to a jewish wedding
it's like you put the bride in the groom
on chairs and like you hoist them into
the air
and it's actually very very scary um
because it's just like all these people
like picking you up and throwing you and
they like don't really care if you fall
you know
and this video was so funny me and ben i
guess i didn't remember like we didn't
even
enjoy we were screaming get us down
we're falling we're falling
it's like it looks like the most unhappy
couple like have you ever showed me that
video i've been would've been like these
people are not gonna last oh i've gotta
see i have to check my timehop today
that's so exciting
yeah september 17th so big big plans
well uh ben and i did
majorly [ __ ] up in making a reservation
for dinner somewhere so at this present
moment
we don't have a dinner reservation and i
really wanted to go to restoration
hardware rooftop which i haven't been to
yet but i heard it's like fabulous
because it's outside
and it's outdoor dining and it's like
all fabulous but they were all booked so
like if someone's listening to this who
can like help me get a reservation there
um yeah someone let's plan a nice
evening for claudia and ben
please like we are [ __ ] um but
honestly like we went to dinner last
night i went to gemma by the way i
wanted to talk about it
which i always say is my favorite
restaurant in the city it's in the
bowery hotel
and they have a huge outdoor dining
usually and so i thought that would be a
good place to go outdoor dine
um and i was right i just have to say
like if you were looking for somewhere
to eat it was so fabulous like
perfect service they are working on a
limited menu because like just
operations have been
you know changed changed but it was a
really fabulous evening it was a
beautiful night and if you're looking
for a place gemma at the bowery hotel i
love that restaurant
oh okay good to know i'm going to dinner
with my friends tonight we're not going
to gemma but
i'll add it to my list of alfresco
experiences that i would
just love to expect that you would
recommend to a friend that i would
recommend to a friend
so today we got to recap so much the
beverly hills reunion and season ended
last night we also had the acm awards
last night which i have many many
thoughts on along with just other things
happening in the news
yes so should we just get right into it
is there anything else you want to talk
about
um i don't think so i mean i could wax
on
about theodore feces you could i could
you have
i would but i think in this time for the
fast side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
okay let's get into it let's get right
into it
starting with the acms last night the
acms
unclear it's the academy of country
music i was like american country music
um yeah the academy of country music
awards were on
they were supposed to happen in las
vegas in april your girls were supposed
to be there we had your tickets to kelly
clarkson the day before
your girl already got a dress and it was
like so sensational so did i
um and then obviously things happened
they pushed it back
to september thinking that that's when
it would happen it didn't happen in the
way that they expected but
they still put on a show from three
different locations the ryman the grand
old opry and the bluebird just sort of
like
taking us around the town of nashville i
thought that the way that they had set
it up virtually was
absolutely sensational okay it's so
strange because i
i actually loved the show like but and
they were just filming different
performances from three different places
and it's like
i just absolutely love country music
that i don't even
know if the show itself or the
production was like better or worse than
say the vmas like maybe i just like
hate the vmas no i'm sorry i
i actually like you were being when we
were watching the vmas like you were
definitely being negative nancy and i
feel like i was really positive about it
and i thought the vmas were good
but seeing what the acms did i thought
it was such a better setup like way less
confusing
i thought the acm integration of google
maps was actually very smart and fun and
cool and fresh
um what i liked also was yes i do like
country music more but i didn't feel
like
anyone was lip-syncing at the country
music yeah um in the acm and i felt like
almost
everyone was on a track at the vmas and
i
the performances were live as they were
happening and and the vms were confusing
because we know a lot of it was
pre-recorded anyways
that's where the comparison's like and
for me i was just wondering if i was
just enjoying it because i love country
music and i could just sit and watch
these performances all day
no i feel like the acms like have been
watching what every virtual award show
was doing and just did it better
um and i feel like the next award show
whatever it's going to be is going to be
even better but i thought the acms were
so well done
clean and organized and everyone showed
up that's the thing it's like the vmas
are there's so much politics in pop
music and it's like
only certain stars like it was literally
the lady gaga and ariana grande
show at the bmw and they won everything
even the awards that they didn't really
deserve like not everyone shows up and
the nominations are predicated on who
shows up where i feel like the acms are
a little bit more reputable in country
music where it's like
everyone gets nominated everyone shows
up and it's like it's a
it's a respect thing so like i was just
so excited that literally everyone i
love performed every time i looked up it
was another performance that i love
i like usually i watch the first half of
a show and then all my favorite
performers have gone and i
go watch real housewives of beverly
hills but there were so many coming up
that i still wanted to see
exactly i thought it was just i just
want to give like a major kudos like i
thought it was so fabulous
i thought it was so fabulous so let's
talk about the winners and then we'll
talk about our favorite performances
okay yes and our least favorite you know
we just have to talk about taylor
swift's outfit
thank you thank you oh yes okay i'm
sorry
i'm so glad that you can see it what do
you mean i can see it i have eyes
okay here are the winners entertainer of
the year was a tie between thomas rhett
and carrie underwood the first ever tie
this is some [ __ ] like i'm sorry
bull [ __ ] [ __ ] duty
okay such a disgrace first of all
award shows awards are meant to be one
they're not meant to be tied so like the
concept of a tie
really bothers me and the concept of a
tie where one of the
um winners is a woman where it's like
they're constantly getting
backlash for like not being inclusive
and not not being equal especially when
it comes to entertainer of the year it's
like
usually there's not even a woman
nominated i just felt like this was a
huge slap in the face to carry underwood
and to like women in country
and it's like if you're going to give it
to her give a turn if you're not going
to give it to her don't give it to her
but like this fake ass
tie and to be honest it was a weird year
so i don't feel like anyone really stood
out
but i certainly don't think thomas rhett
stood out no i mean
it's so crazy how much i love country
music and you know i listened to it all
and thomas wrote us at the top of the
charts and like
i just like really don't subscribe like
his music comes up on all my playlists
and i know a lot of his music and it's
good it's fine
i just i don't think that he was
entertainer of the year first of all and
he's just not my particular jam but i
know he's like a lot of people's jams
but i just thought like first of all if
the acms were smart this was like a
weird year where there wasn't a clear
winner and they should have given it to
a woman
just so they can like address the issue
where it's like all the female artists
are constantly talking about how like
country radio country music and like the
country awards just are not equal so
it's like just give it to a woman
so but then you're saying say that the
academy voted and i guess
maybe they have an even number of
academics yeah
and it was a tie and you're saying just
give it to her so but you're kind of
like being counter-intuitive because
it's like she doesn't deserve it we
should just give it to her to like but
see if she won the tie
she would have deserved it and it would
have propped up women in country so like
yes technically like she would have
cheated a little bit
but i just think like they could have
just given it to her yeah i mean i
at first i was like oh that's so like
lame like a tie
um but if they're if the academics voted
and there really was a tie i doubt like
this is with some sort of like move on
their part
like i think it comes off lame i don't
think they make like moves like this
i think the the eight the academy of
country music like is the academy of
country music they don't just give
awards based on popularity and like
who's gonna show up and and what
no they definitely don't and so that's
why i just think it was a tie
i'm not happy about it i'm not gonna lie
yeah it's pretty lame it's lame and i
just feel like
not only does carrie underwood like
unequivocally deserve it for this year
last year and the year before
i just think it also sends a great
message to finally like acknowledge
and not to give a woman like a half an
award yeah well she got the whole one
they both got you know what i mean
yeah female artist of the year was marin
morris i was shocked by that but not on
unhappy not unhappy they were all the
artist of the year to me male artist of
the year
lou combs hey duo of the year
dan and shay group of the year old
dominion okay old dominion got
so much respect at the acms last night
and when i turned it on it was in the
middle of their performance
and i was just like thrilled to see them
i forgot like
how good looking they all are and i just
like love them so much and i feel like
they're
like my favorite band i think i would
say yeah they're so they're so great and
when they were singing songs that like
weren't even my favorite songs that i
never like saved to spotify but like i
knew the songs and i was like
now i need to save it my favorite group
is still lady a
i think that they have just been snubbed
this year because they put out like such
a great album
but i think old dominion completely
earned that award
agreed new female artist of the year
teneal towns love her
love her did you watch her performance
yes i did it was not
it was i was just like so excited i was
like when she was just like a woman
standing on the stage with her guitar i
was like she's seeing somebody's dog
this is gonna be yeah i was like this is
gonna be like a performance that we
just are all looking back on when this
girl like blows up
and um she was nervous yeah but it was
still good i like that song me too
new male artist of the year riley green
um cutie
okay so i was watching with
my friends nikki and jordan i can't
believe riley green beat morgan wallin
like to me
i can't believe morgan wants artist put
some respect on his name like
i i was shocked to see that i was
shocked not only to see him sing whiskey
glasses
again like seeing seven summers but also
that he's still in
the new male artist category it's weird
also i feel like riley
and by the way this is not meant to be a
slight in any way because i actually
love his music and i think he's like the
hottest man alive who looks so much like
a young brett eldridge
um i feel like he's a uh he reminds me
of meghan trainor where it's like the
industry is trying to make him famous
like
literally i've never sought out his
music and somehow i know it it's like
it's always coming up on my spotify
on music choice like on the radio i just
feel like there like there is a machine
behind riley
interesting i had never aside from like
grandpa's i wish grandpa's never die
which i
really like that song i never like heard
or thought of him again and then
he was performing last night i like
picked my head up because i recognized
the song and i was like what
is this and i was like and who is that
stud album of the year what you see is
what you get by luke holmes of course
which was the album of the year single
of the year god's country by blake
shelton
who deserves even though i actually
despise that song oh i love it
god's country it's like a little too
much for me but at the end of his speech
when he was like i think he thanked god
and i was like
for making this country right thank you
thank you god and your country
song of the year one man band by old
dominion i thought that was an
interesting
choice yeah it was a great song but i
don't know if it was song of the year
but i also think that like that the ones
that were nominated just didn't speak to
me
video of the year remember you young by
thomas rhett and
actually i know we just like took a
massive dump on thomas rat
that's that song is really beautiful and
the video like margaret made me watch
and she was like watching me cry
it was literally beautiful i actually i
take back a lot of what i said about
thomas red that song is like sickeningly
beautiful
it is and so i'm glad that it got the
respect that it deserved
um those were they didn't do so many
award giving out speeches
last night it was really so many
performances so let's talk about some of
our
favorites yeah i mean obviously like i
showed up for taylor swift and she over
delivered like first of all
that song is so sensational and what
warms the cockles of my swifty heart is
taylor swift and a guitar like that's
how she started like
it's just that's my true and all the
other accoutrements are
fabulous but all i really need in this
life is taylor swift singing acoustic
with a guitar
i love betty it is my favorite song and
her being at the acm is just like the
meaning
it was so there for me she sounded
amazing
unbelievable the visual the like the the
lights
there was no frou-frou like it it was
stunning
it was the performance was a 10 out of
10. but you know my rdh has been acting
up and i would legitimately be
remiss devastated and genuinely
heartbroken if i didn't address the
outfit
if i didn't address the equestrian pants
and the sequin long sleeve shirt like
oh and if i didn't address i'm sorry the
bangs
the bangs by the way someone needs to
make a tick tock with her bangs and use
the
the tic toc song not the bangs okay i
guess
that hairstyle is her vibe for this
arrow yes we know that every era she has
a signature hairstyle so if you look
back on pictures you'll be able to tell
exactly what time period it was because
of the hairstyle which is an iconic move
an iconic move i hate this hairstyle
hate
hate hate hate and it couldn't have
matched less with the sequin atlantic
city top
no the which did not match the malibu
ranch pants
yeah it was it was so strange no no
first like and she is
glamorous like to the nth degree i feel
like no stone is left unturned with her
looks like it's always like 10 out of 10
best of the best some of my favorite
looks but like i it's like literally
like
someone took over her body and put that
outfit on because i don't believe she
would ever walk out of her house in that
like it was shocking no it was so
disturbing
um and i saw that the whole outfit is
stella mccartney because you know they
partnered with
stuff and if like i just don't know what
happened honestly like shame on you
stella mccartney like for even creating
something that ugly and like putting it
in front of taylor and like
make like you know it's hard like you're
a shop designer and then like you see
and it's like
just because something has a fendi tag
like it could be ugly but like you don't
know because it's fantastic yeah when
you love a designer so much like
sometimes you can't see
if it's ugly or not right you can't see
out of the designer haze yeah and i feel
as though that's what happened to taylor
i
i hope so it was she there's like
it's so crazy because like thinking
about her coming back to the acm for
first time in seven years like
performing this country song like
there's so many cute things like she
could have done and worn like just
subtle and that was just and you know
what sometimes like
a celebrity or an artist wears something
that i don't understand fully at the
time yes
but it grows on me over time i don't
think that this will i know for a fact
that this won't
um but other outfits i thought that
kelsey ballerini looked so amazingly
sickeningly stunning in her performance
dress
and she did an instagram story like had
so much fun at the acms and i literally
responded i'm like
you looked sickening she goes oh my god
i did is that bad
oh my god sweetie no it's good no she
lit it was funny because i was like
thinking about the outfits i feel like
for men and country music like it's you
know very
standard standard hat boots and i was
like
for a female country artist in 2020 like
the look is changing
yes but you know there's still those big
things that
a country artist like loves to wear and
i i thought that kelsey ballerini was
like the perfect pop country star last
night and i thought also marin mars
while she went in a totally different
direction like more of like a retro look
i thought she looked fantastic okay and
i feel like carrie underwood when she
did that
that little dress awful i knew you were
gonna like it and i literally hated it
so much like oh my god first
little ankles poking out there is a
special place in hell for dresses that
landslide
oh my gosh it needs to either go above
your knee
no between your knee and your ankle
or just to the floor like this little
teacup i
hate hate hate oh my god dresses i loved
her dress the silhouette it's just like
so june carter cash like so stunning
gross hated it oh my god i
loved it i hate those dresses like maybe
maybe like
the most sickening like no i can't even
think of an instance where i would think
that that's an appropriate dress like i
hate teacup dresses that is so crazy but
it's so
you yeah um okay i want to talk about my
favorite performances aside from taylor
swift it was just like a marvel but
i loved luke holmes obviously always
morgan wallin like i
absolutely love him like i have a crush
on him i think he's so cute so much
presence and like the mullet
is just iconic iconic and the denim like
duds
but i thought the best performance was
someone who i've never even noticed like
in my
career as a fan of country music um i
was so like take i didn't even know the
song but
he was just so good eric church by the
way like welcome
to the club like everyone knows no eric
everyone knows eric church but like he
just made such an impact on me like and
you know what i think it was i think
because he wears the sunglasses and
there's no audience so i think a lot of
the performers like didn't really know
where to look and
where they were all amazing but there's
a little awkwardness when you're
performing to an empty room
but because he was wearing sunglasses he
didn't have to look anywhere and he just
like was really into it
and the woman singing with him and i
just thought it was like
incredible yeah you know eric church i
mean i was on twitter like wanting to
see people's reactions to the
entertainer of the year and like a lot
of people were up in arms at eric church
like
constantly gets like slighted because
he's not really into the fame aspect of
music he's just into the music and
apparently like he puts on three hour
concerts like multiple nights in a row
like and loves his fan so much and he's
just like this icon
he reminds me a lot like and him and
like his following remind me of like
bruce springsteen like
how people like die for him and like
garth brooks also whereas the concerts
are like these
religious experiences yeah like grateful
dead and i feel like we should right
exactly and i feel like we should get
into eric church because i mean i used
to listen to eric chartrick when i first
started
like um listening to country like
springsteen oh we actually had a song
called springsteen maybe that's why they
remind me of each other
but um i agree i thought his performance
was great and a lot of people were
really upset that he didn't win
entertainer of the year because he's
been nominated three times and has never
won
i was just like so impressed and i've
seen him around on the circuit before
you know i think we even saw him perform
on stagecoach i just
i just thought his performance was so
good and also um miranda lambert like
was so cute and so and i loved her
outfit too and like they all all the
like big women in country like we're all
wearing like country
pop outfits but they were all so
different from one another and i just
thought it was interesting
i have said this before i've completely
done a 180 on miranda lambert like i
love her and i love her new music and i
loved her outfit and i love that she was
at the bluebird like
singing blueberries right right no it
wasn't the meaning was not lost on me
whatsoever
and i i can't apologize enough for ever
having said like
anything bad about miranda lambert
because i love her yeah
no it was a really interesting night and
it and it
felt as close to normal as we've gotten
in a while that's exactly what it was
oh and i loved kane brown's performance
and i loved how he used the
empty audience to have like background
singers
and i hadn't heard that song before it
was so beautiful but i i loved like how
he used the space oh my god you haven't
heard that song it's all over the place
snitch showed it to me yeah and also
like i just listened to my my saved
songs over and over if it weren't for
you and margo like i would literally
never have evolved past like
red taylor swift like i don't listen to
new music but now i've been recently
listening to my daily mixes on spotify
which i owe like they're such a great
thing that they do
they make you like a personalized mix
every day and they put my favorites in
there and then other things they think
i'll like and that's really how i find
new music but it's like
sometimes old do you happen to have a
story about amazon music today
no okay so did you know amazon music
launch podcast yeah so i downloaded the
app to see if the toast was on there and
it is so you can now listen to podcasts
on amazon music which is just an
interesting fact
and the toast is on there guys the
streaming wars are catching up with the
podcast industry and i just think it's
going to be like the craziness
no i know and i'm just like so glad to
be a part of it you know what i'm saying
i agree okay so there's more places for
you to consume the toast we'd love to
see it we absolutely love to see it
so those were the acms any anything else
no i don't think so i just i really
really really enjoyed it which is so
rare
yeah me too it's selena gomez rare
okay next up um really big story today
emily radakowski accuses photographer
jonathan letter
in an essay about abuse of power so
emily ratakowski wrote an essay on
tuesday for new york magazines the cut
about abusive power
and in it she details a 2012 nude photo
shoot at photographer jonathan letter's
home
that she says turned physical so i read
the essay that she wrote and it was it
was so
moving and and the story is so crazy so
it's um called buying myself back and in
the beginning she talks about
like image rights for celebrities how
you know
they get sued by it's crazy by companies
when they post paparazzi photos of
themselves and like they don't even own
their own image and
then she was also talking about how an
artist richard prince i think like
he makes art where he comments on
celebrities instagrams like something
like kind of crazy and then
like pretty much like paints it or
screenshots it and then like sells it
and she's crazy
yeah and she was a subject of two of the
pieces and like everyone was telling her
like this is such a big deal
and so she wound up buying one with her
boyfriend at the time
who um when they broke up like he tried
to keep
one of the pieces that she was gifted
and like again she's just always like
fighting to own
right herself exactly then she told a
story about
how when before she was in blurred lines
or gotten girl when she was an
up-and-coming model
her asian sent her on a shoot um to the
catskills
with this photographer jonathan letter
and um
it was like a very um like an
uncomfortable shooting experience
for her like there was a lot of alcohol
involved and he like really he was just
like
inappropriate obviously and um there was
like a
like a sexual incident between the two
of them and the pictures were just like
kind of
provocative and he wanted like she was
nude in some of them and
it was for a magazine and the pictures
wound up in the magazine and that was
that
and then once she became this huge
household name he took all of the
polaroids from that shoot
and started selling books like emily
radakowski and she like
was trying to get him to stop because
those are her images that she didn't
her agent never signed that they could
be used however you want like they could
be used for that magazine
specifically and so she tried to like
go you know stop him from doing it and
then it became like this whole story the
pictures emily ratakowski doesn't want
you to see
god he printed the book like three
separate editions of the book
and the pic like it's just
this like misuse of her image that she
doesn't own and she's just like trying
like
speaking out finally on what happened
between the two of them like
one i think people i never heard the
story about like these images of her
being used
in this way um so i think she was
telling her story
on that like why it's so wrong why he
even used those images and also what
happened between the two of them
while they were shooting and he really
abused his power she's like a
young up and coming just trying to like
do what she thought she had to do
and you know try to be like she said um
you know
you never know who's they're shooting
with after like you want them to like
you and
right and say that you're easy to work
with
so it was really a disturbing um
story and now
people are talking about this this guy
and then i also saw that um
this woman posted on instagram who was
married to him briefly in like the early
2000's like praising emily radakowski
just kind of
i guess like corroborating her story i'm
saying like that
there was like some really tumultuous
things that happened in the marriage
like beyond like he was having an affair
and just like this abusive
vibe and it was actually a really
powerful instagram post i really liked
it
yeah so she says that she remembers uh
jonathan letter's fingers being inside
of her explaining that the action hurt
and that she pulled his fingers out with
force she said she didn't say anything
afterwards but that letter stood up
abruptly and left to go upstairs
in a statement to usa today on wednesday
heather tynan editorial director of
his imperial publishing company said he
completely denies her
outrageous libelous allegations of being
quote assaulted
you know [ __ ] off like just don't say
anything you're an animal don't now
accuse her of lying like that's
that's so morally corrupt so morally
right now this stuff with
like and it really is a problem like
with the rights images image rights like
i know the celebrities posting
instagrams of themselves like i'm sure
that's really like [ __ ] annoying but
like
but the fact that you can use these
photos
of her that she didn't never like signed
off and being used in this way and like
like profiting off of her image is so
sick
and there has to be a way around
like you know yeah no i mean i think the
paparazzi thing is so crazy like
gigi adidas sent recently had to pay a
paparazzi 150 000
because she posted a picture of herself
that he literally took like as he was
getting in her personal space
like to me that just makes no [ __ ]
sense yeah i mean this is the same thing
it's like
the like the fact that you're in the
picture like means nothing
yeah it might it could be anyone because
you have absolutely no rights yeah
so that's crazy well people are really
responding i feel like very positively
to this emily rajkowski story
um and i think it's great i think it was
a great platform for she's a good writer
like a good platform for her to tell her
story
yeah i agree so i hope that i don't know
if she's going to continue to pursue
like him
ceasing and assisting the production of
these books but i hope that if she does
that
she gets the outcome that is fair i also
really hope that like the fashion
industry um
and like the modeling industry like
follows suit and like stops working with
this photographer because there have
been like crazy allegations
to a lot of very high profile fashion
photographers whose careers go
seemingly unfazed you know they're still
at vogue they're still doing this
big shoot met gala it's like what yeah
what
and it's like really disappointing um
so i feel like this is such a big story
i really hope that there are some like
ramifications because he shouldn't be
in the same room as young models yes
like ever again
ever again um next story also
this is just like crazy kanye west posts
a video of himself peeing on one of his
grammys
yeah i saw so kanye's taken to twitter
again and he gave one of his grammys a
golden shower
in the midst of what page six calls a
twitter meltdown but
you know that's a subjective term on
wednesday um the rapper tossed one of
his 21 trophies into the toilet and peed
all over it
trust me i won't stop he captioned the
video which he shared on twitter
after publishing screenshots of his
contract with def jam music group
which is a subsidiary of universal so he
is trying to help artists get their
masters back
specifically trying to own his own
masters which like the irony here
of like this whole thing um like as a
taylor swift
kanye west i mean taylor swift kim
kardashian like equalizer
the irony is not lost on me here yeah
but he said the artist deserves to own
our own masters artists are starving
without tours i'm gonna go get our
masters for all artists
pray for me okay i just like it's really
hard for me not to like make this about
taylor swift and they need to team up
they need to team up but i do find it
interesting um and i'm
gonna continue to like look out for like
how the media and the public
responds to connie going this route you
know like um
twitter rampages and peeing on his
grammys whereas i feel like taylor swift
like was
made to seem like she was insane when
she was like literally just like being
so civilized
yeah i'll just be interested i don't
think that this is gonna get any more
respect
than no but i feel like it highlights
not only the fact that this is a major
issue for artists but like how taylor
swift in my opinion like went about it
in a very mature
civil way when like people were giving
her [ __ ] for being annoying
yeah i don't know if it was like super
mature and civil because she had the
opportunity to buy them back and then
she didn't and it just became like
you know but okay so like technically
like
technically according to taylor like she
never had an opportunity to buy them
back
in a fair way in a so she actually
wasn't fair she had to do it was like
labor she had to give them an album to
buy one back so literally she would have
had to produce seven more albums in
order to get her albums back
she couldn't have ever wasn't there like
us whatever scooter braun paid
that offer was never made to her okay
the only offer scott said
stay with me for one more album then
i'll give you one album then another one
so seven for seven
got it i don't know if um this is gonna
work but i do think that i don't think
it's gonna work um that he makes a good
point that
i and he said this before that pretty
much like the way that artists unless
you're like
you you know seeing ahead of things and
planning and
hiring your own people like the way that
artists are set up it's like you make
yes you're making a lot of money from
your albums and your tours but they also
have you paying like your managers and
your agents and all these other fees and
like
remember when he said like when when
kanye was like broke
and he restructured his whole business
um but i guess without tours like
artists who they don't own their music
and like
they're struggling you know like it's an
interesting thing
struggling relatively um the music
industry
is structured in a specific way to not
only keep
the artists at like an arm's length from
like the real money that they're making
but also that they can never own
anything they do and that's what a lot
of artists
most notably taylor swift have been
talking about for so long and this is
like
kind of similar well actually not at all
but it's just like a
common thread and there are a lot of
artists who like speak up about it like
leave their like chance of rapper
doesn't have a label
um oh like it's not so common but i feel
like now with the absence of touring
it might be a little bit more obvious
like how much artists are being duped
from the amount of money that they're
generating
yeah but then they also they do sign
these contracts when they're coming up
because
when they're generating that amount of
money if this particular
record label didn't take a chance on
them and put all these marketing dollars
into them
so it's definitely like an interesting
business issue for these artists
um i don't know it's like hard to feel
bad for pop stars because like
oh sorry you're living in a four million
dollar mansion when you could be living
in an 8 million dollar mansion like it's
really hard to feel bad for them but you
know at the end of the day it's like
business ethics like what's right is
right and what's wrong is wrong
yeah and i think that everyone could be
still making money but there should be a
restructuring because i
maybe this was like how it started the
business but like right like
change today with like streaming
services and it's not like you're buying
albums and
maybe it's just time for some
restructuring agreed so
and maybe that's what kind he's trying
to say for sure next up some more
music news sort of casey musgraves
reaches a divorce settlement with her ex
rusty
kelly looks like she'll have some new
heartbreak songs on her next album
casey musgraves and rusty and kelly
finally reached a settlement in their
divorce tmc reported
tmc tmz reported on wednesday as part of
the settlement musgraves and kelly
put their home on the market when it
sells casey will get 84.4 percent of the
proceeds
and rustin will get the rest i'm sure
she paid 84
when they bought it and then by the way
like that's just crazy like i'm so
curious
in as the logistics into the financial
logistics behind like celebrity couples
like
because each celebrity themselves no
matter how big or small is like their
own industry so it's like
celebrity marriages are always
complicated and like i just like makes
me
like interested to know that she paid 84
of the house and they agreed to enforce
their prenuptial agreement so all they
need to do is have a judge sign off on
the divorce
so this seems like as amicable and clean
as it gets you know wow that's like fast
and easy
yeah wow prenup and it doesn't sound
like either one of them is like
contesting it or applying for stuff so
asking for like alimony so that book
will be closed soon that's fast you know
clean divorces are the best you know
just wash your hands and get out
wash your hands and get out i really
miss casey like
last night's acms just they would
definitely had a casey sized hole
it was there was like a glaring hole
from her absence yeah and like with all
of the
like country pop queens like everyone
with their vibe like we were missing the
kc vibe
oh a performance we didn't talk about
was pink and keith urban oh that's when
i turned it off that's because i didn't
know that song but i love the combo and
i love how pink respects the [ __ ] out of
country music
that wasn't live was it no it was like
on a green screen they weren't even
together yeah like i think they
filmed it like a few of their houses
yeah that that's that's that's actually
why i turned it off so now i don't feel
bad for being right about the vmas i
don't like that [ __ ]
yeah pre-recorded is annoying like just
put it on youtube i felt like i was
watching a video game yeah no it felt
like you're watching like a youtube
video music video
yeah a bad one yeah um fifth and final
story one of our
favorite people here at the toast is
releasing a food memoir
stanley tucci it will be titled taste
what my life through food oh my god okay
well stanley tucci is iconic
for so many things but i didn't know his
cooking was one of those things stanley
tucci has a full plate ahead of him the
award-winning actor 59 who once sat next
to jackie on a plane
no he didn't oh my god it was not
stanley eugene it was working you're
just jealous
the only two cheat okay first of all we
were in l.a
for the oscars he was there we were
flying back to new york
you don't go to the oscars and then fly
back coach exit row next to jackie
i mean on the way back stanley it was by
the way like it was definitely extra
legroom
and he's just a regular guy you know he
doesn't want like to be
he said like i just don't want to be
like jackie was texting us oh my god i'm
next to santa's g oh my god oh my god
we landed we got the text we got up to
exit she was like that's him and we were
like
are you [ __ ] serious it was not
stanley tucci okay
maybe you're right but you know who i
think it actually really might have been
who
that guy from the kingsman who sings
take me home country road when
the thing explodes by the way one
thousand percent that was him yeah
what's his name
that guy was such a hero oh my god his
name what was it in
king's men kingsman cass i feel like
he's from something else too he's from a
lot of things okay his name
is oh he was merlin mark strong
and what else is he in i'm about to tell
you by the way that's such a good call
like that's who it was
he's family fuji he is family he gets
all the roles that stanley chuchi like
his schedule conflicts
okay he's in like a lot of things that
we didn't see oh he's in zero dark 30
but i don't remember him from that
um he's definitely like from something
specific kingsman but like there are so
many
movies here like sherlock holmes shazam
the green lantern brothers
uh brothers grimsby tinker taylor
soldier spy
1917 imitation game but like we didn't
see any of those yeah well whatever by
the way that is who you were sitting
next to but back to stanley tucci
he's writing a cook book titled taste my
life through
food it's described as an intimate and
charming reflection of chuchi's life and
relationship to food
it will feature anecdotes and memories
from his childhood in westchester new
york
as well oh my god stanley tucci is not
from like london as well as his culinary
experiences preparing for roles
in foodie films like big night and julie
and julia
i don't know this feels like a slight to
actual chefs like he played one on tv
and now we can write a cookie
the hell out of things i have two like
interesting facts about stanley not
interesting facts two of my favorite
things about stanley two
okay one he is related i mean he is
married to
emily blunt's sister wow that's
beautiful especially
considering do they meet on the set of
devil wires prada oh i don't know
they did yes oh my gosh so cute so him
and john krazenski are like related
which i just think is like an
interesting thing
that's a fun double date yeah a very
respectable double date
and then my other favorite thing about
stanley tucci was he was irrecognizable
and some people might not remember that
he was
lovely bones i was literally gonna say
that yes he was the villain in lovely
bones which is an amazing movie
and other people might not remember that
is also circa ronan's
first big break yes sir cerrone by the
way speaking of her we watched lady bird
oh we did well over our trip i
couldn't believe that i was watching
like the movie that had so much oscar
buzz
i guess i just assume when a movie has
oscar buzz it's like boring and
historical
but this was just like a like a
coming-of-age story it could have been
it was literally like
to all the boys i loved before like you
know what i realized i
absolutely loathe a coming-of-age story
oh i disagree i love it coming in no
like
because if that's what a coming-of-age
story is like where nothing happens we
just watch someone like
grow up coverage six months not
interested
yeah i just ladybird really shocked me i
don't know why i just thought it would
be something more serious and like more
like good morning i thought it would be
moved yeah no it was
literally i thought it would say
something it was the kissing booth like
it was so bad
it was so bad um okay listen to what
stanley tucci has been in because it's
like
respect yeah devil wears prada of course
lovely bones
of course hunger games remember he's
caesar milan of course
caesar milan caesar milan is the
celebrity dog trainer yeah yeah but he
was the guy on the capitol
i know but it his name is caesar
his last name is not milan that is so
funny big night julian julia captain
america easy a oh yeah he plays emma
stone's dad
burlesque oh my god what we also watched
that over our vacation
that's what you think of when you sex
when you hear burlesque i mean i think a
million things i think of
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
give it up give it up
that is literally the best movie it's so
good we watch it like all the time yeah
we watched it over vacation i mean
cher comes dangerously close to ruining
it and ruining it
no i think she's tina aguilera and
stanley tucci
and julianne hoff and kristen bell
chick vulture keep it on track totally
yeah the chair
you were you tried uh if you had had one
more solo song like the movie actually
would have been turned off by me but
that one we gave you one with the chair
and i love you by the way
my favorite scene in the movie is how
like she's had a long night and the club
is really weighing on her they're having
all these financial problems
and stanley choo choo's like sweetie you
got to run this number not even standing
wait it's terence j
also another great addition in the cast
so terence j
is like cher we need you to run through
this number and she's like but i'm
tired and then she's like okay and she
sings this awful song on this chair and
she's like
so into it it's just like it comes
really close to ruining the movie
you said it perfectly yeah he's also in
spotlight such a good movie have you
seen it
of course i've seen spotlight an amazing
movie beauty and the beast
oh my god of course but his voice his
voice yes his when he comes to life at
the end spoiler alert
made in manhattan oh my god who is he in
manhattan i don't know there's just so
many good
he's such an iconic actor he's been kick
catrice an american girl
what wow there's an american girl moving
yeah i saw it it was good it's okay
because they're like it's kind of like
historical fiction because they're like
they're like all have been through war
yes and i think kit
is like a depression era oh um kid
and so it's it's a lot that's like a
funny thing about i loved american girl
dolls we had and it was like so such an
exciting thing like you really
identified
with your american girl doll but i
always forget that they had like a like
a historical background like some of
them were like literally like
world war ii veterans like it was crazy
it was crazy yeah it's crazy kid was
mine that's why i saw the movie i was
molly and it was abigail wrestling yeah
abigail wrestling as a child literally
is such an
icon like little miss sunshine will
literally never not be
an incredible movie no abigail wrestling
as a child has like the best
roster of films like some of the best
things i've ever seen
oh great um oh my god that's so funny
so yeah stanley tucci writing a food
book are you gonna get it
i think you are i don't think so i've
never bought a celebrity like food
because i never knew how to cook until
yesterday
um and so i think that if i did
buy one i don't i don't even know whose
i would buy first but it wouldn't be
stanley's honestly because i think his
his probably his recipes are probably
like really fancy and you know i just
want
some like good cooking it's probably
like chrissy teigen cravings
yeah probably um that's funny like you
don't buy celebrity cookbooks i
exclusively only buy like celebrity
books i'm also going to start nia
rivera's book did i tell you that i've
heard it's great and there's some good
glee gossip in there oh wow i think
that's my next journey oh that's good
that'll be good okay let's dive into tv
recap because beverly hills was on last
night
and it was infuriating i'm not gonna lie
like it was
sad it was so sad to see denise go out
that way with a tear in her eye
and to be honest like i know that even
before this the season aired like
this brandy denise drama was like so
hyped up and it was supposed to be like
this salacious thing but it never gave
me that
and every time they talked about it i
just like rolled my eyes i would have
talked about
literally anything else and the whole
episode because they saved the best for
the third
the whole episode last night was about
brandy denise and it was like we're so
beyond the point of
but also so was the last episode so it
was weird they kept like coming back to
it and then when we finally felt like we
put it to
bed they we talked about something else
and then andy was like rinna and denise
why aren't you friends anymore it's like
yeah it was like choppy um honestly i
just like love garcelle and i love how
she protects denise and i feel like
she's such a good friend
and i hope her and denise stay friends
like even though denise is not coming
back i was so glad she called out reno
when i was like
you should have come to me as a friend
and it's like what part of anything that
you did this season would make denise
think you were her friend
no literally garcelle was the rinna
police and i was living for it like
if denise had come to rinna and said
rina
listen i did this i can't be talking
about it like i have to protect my
family
please like help me yeah at the reunion
rina would have said
but you told me that it was true a
hundred percent rena has proved to be
literally the least
loyal friend and the fact that she like
expects everyone to come to her and like
finds fault in them for not confiding in
her it's like you're literally the last
person on planet earth any of these
women should ever confide in right and
like
rina okay let's play devil's advocate
and say like rin is really just a truth
warrior and wants to get to the truth
but also is a really 20 years good
friend to denise and wants to be a good
friend
why'd you print the text messages like
that's above and beyond
also to rin a smoking gun in this
situation is that the text messages
don't equal what denise described their
friendship acquaintance and i'm sorry
but
that's just not hard evidence no by the
way
like that that doesn't that doesn't show
me without a shadow of a doubt
that everything that brandy said is true
no see like what i find so frustrating
about this is like
i do believe brandy like to be honest
like i do
and i still take denise's side because
at the end of the day it's nobody's
business
like uh the women are the women are like
truth warriors like they're so
you know um hell bent on finding out the
truth when it's like
i don't even care about the truth i
think you're a piece of [ __ ] for trying
to find out the truth like it's not your
business
yeah and renault said a few times like
whenever it would be like thrown back at
her like why are you doing this she was
like it's not about me and it's like
then why are you in the middle of it and
like how did it become like reno versus
denise when it was like
teddy and kyle's tea to begin with you
know like rina just inserted herself and
like was so excited and so happy
to take down denise and like show that
she's a hypocrite and i think rina's
theory
that denise like wanted to change her
image from the prior season
while it i understand that it sounds
nice like i don't believe it at all and
you know what makes me realize that is
denise's tagline this season was like
i may not like have a hat fairy tale but
i always get a happy ending and it's
like if she's trying
to she's trying to move away from that
like she wouldn't be saying it in the
beginning of every episode you know i
just don't know what lisa rena's motives
were and it's like she just wants to be
a bad friend to everyone
and i just i've turned on her so
completely completely and i'm i'm i was
so like
i wasn't even like angry i was like
upset watching last night's episode
because not only is denise like a
respectable woman who got like [ __ ]
bamboozled by this group i feel like i'm
alone in that thinking i feel like
everyone's like
everyone is just obsessed with like the
inconsistency in denise's lies because
denise's lives are all over the place
and she's
obviously lying but it's not about the
truth it's not your [ __ ] business
it's about the way that you treat your
friends and like it's not like
there's this rumor going around that
denise like murdered someone
right did you also um do you remember in
the episode when they were
talking about that scene at kyle's
barbecue where denise and aaron left and
aaron like squeezed her hand and was
like
don't tell me to shut up i'm just rip
your hand off whatever i'm gonna crush
your hands and everyone was like all
worried that it was like a toxic
behavior like honestly i didn't think
there was maybe i just read it
differently like i don't think there was
anything wrong with that like
i think he was saying like i'm so mad
i'm gonna crush your hand like not like
i'm gonna
hurt you yeah yeah i thought everyone
was being like a little dramatic i
thought that that statement was
a little uh it was a little weird for
sure scary but i didn't find it scary
like even when i hadn't noticed it on
the show
but when they highlighted it i didn't
really it didn't alarm me
until all the women were like i was
worried yeah it's like everyone takes to
everything that denise is saying now
like so literally when she was like
aaron's watch that and he was like i'm
scared of you and then andy was like
why is he scared of you he's like
totally
i i like if i were denise i would
obviously not return but i can't speak
in hyperbole like you can't
right only but only for denise because
everyone else is just like crazy all
over the place and by the way they say
open and honest one more time
one more time it's infuriating so i'm
like 100
turned on kyle i'm like i'm sorry on ted
i'm 100 turned on right now and i'm like
75 turned on kyle like i'm almost done
with her
yeah because it really did feel like she
was like pulling all the puppet strings
and then showed up to the reunion been
like if you were just
honest and like honestly not only do i
find that
be honest thing to be like so dumb i
also find it to be boring television
like that's
we're not true this isn't the real truth
tellers of beverly hills okay yeah
yeah and i understand like brennan is
now every time she does something sort
of
out of line she's like we're on a tv
show um
but the way that candace and giselle
handled telling ashley like that news
about her husband is like
the exact appropriate appropriate way
that they could have
done that for hundreds especially
considering like
candace and ashley aren't even friends
and yeah rena and denise are friends for
20 years and then also rena brought up
heather locklear oh okay so that's when
denise started to cry
and they said google it which i did not
i did what does it say okay so
um heather locklear was married to
richie
sambora for like 11 years and
while denise was married to charlie
sheen heather locklear and charlie sheen
did a tv show together so like the
couples became friends
heather locklear and richard sambora
divorced
and denise started dating richie
and i guess she was married to charlie
no i think her and charlie are over but
i guess like the
what renault was trying to say is like
and i think heather locklear has said
this that like denise stole her husband
um which denise has said is not what
happened what happened
was that i think denise's mom had cancer
at the time and and so did one of
richie's parents and they like bonded
over that
and then a relationship bloomed from
there so i think reyna was like
just throwing out like this obviously
painful thing where denise lost a friend
um and just trying to make it seem like
denise is a friend loser no
just trying to make it seem like denise
is a bad friend like a bad friend like a
home wrecker
and this and that and everything she
started to cry right and then i guess
brandi
told like dailymail tv yesterday that
heather locklear had like reached out to
her over dm saying like thank you for
bringing the truth to light
because like now heather locklear feels
like vindicated because she's been
trying to say that denise stole her man
i'm just like not here and it's a denise
take down i don't know why but i'm not
no i'm not especially when it's like
apples and oranges like
okay so e whatever happened in the 90s
10 years ago yeah in the early 2000s
like
i'm watching real housewives of beverly
hills right now and like i thought that
was a low blow by reynolds 100
she obviously knew that's a sore subject
for denise and denise was like [ __ ]
shook
i feel like denise's experience on the
show is going to really deter
like real like seedless celebrities from
potentially joining
you know what in general that's fine by
me because i'm never enthused about i
wasn't enthused about eileen davidson i
was not enthused about lisa arena and i
wasn't enthused about denise and now
i've come to
like you know i would loop in eileen
davidson in that no but like
her and rina came on together and they
were both like d-list soap stars
they were literally on the same playing
field
when they came on yeah um and
so i that's fine i don't i don't mind if
some actresses don't want to come on the
show yeah i i agree i like especially
they think that like they're on they're
playing by different rules right i like
finding like those jewels like those
sudden strikes like those just like
quiet rich women
yeah garcelle yeah even though
garcelle's naturally so true
oh wow interesting um but all in all it
was like a decent season i could have
used a lot less brandy and denise drama
because it didn't end up giving me what
i thought it was gonna give me like
salacious juicy gossip like
it ended up just being really really sad
and now that denise
is not coming back like it just feels
like rina
and co have won that
is just frustrating to me because then
they'll continue to do this sort of
thing where it's like
no one wants like no one wanted to see
that last night i don't think they need
to replace denise i think they need to
make sutton like a full-time housewife
and i think the group is actually pretty
solid
yeah i agree we have new york on tonight
um which is part two of the reunion
we didn't recap part one of the reunion
but we'll do it all tomorrow but i
actually really enjoyed the in-person
reunion it was just like a breath of
fresh air even though like it was a lame
season
i was like still getting life from the
reunion because we haven't had an
in-person reunion in so
long yeah and i was really glad tinsley
was there to finally shed some light on
why she thinks jordan hates her because
that was literally the craziness
and i guess we could just talk about it
right now but like the absolute disgrace
of bravo cutting out that footage from
last season when
not only we found out that scott lent
money to john which is crazy in and of
itself but that dorinda threw such a fit
that they literally had to get tinsley
out of the house because they were
worried about her safety like yeah why
that was cut and we have to sit through
that shitty ass scene and then we have
to
sit through this whole season being like
why does jiren do hate tinsley did
anything ever happen between the two and
it's like this huge bombshell where they
have footage like that is honestly
unforgivable and i feel like when they
show during this phone call some of it
sounded familiar i think they just did
in the promotion they did
when she's in the hallway on the phone
with john and so it just makes me
realize like some things
do get taken out that are beyond
disparaging that are
past the line and so when denise was
asking bravo to take it out like
it wasn't beyond the realm of
possibility right
yeah i thought andy like did a decent
job at like being in the middle but i
think he could have protected denise
like a little bit more i agree
especially when like i feel like the
whole premise of why i don't care about
the affairs because
at some point it's like you are outing
denise maybe she's not open if
she is bisexual um and that's just like
unethical to me and like that's where i
draw the line i thought maybe andy would
like
understand and respect that but he was
just doing his job yeah
it was not an easy job to do so but the
season's over i'm going to miss the
beverly hills housewives but we have a
lot of good stuff coming up
um orange county's premiering and salt
lake city is like kind of close
and don't be tardy so exciting you guys
and keeping up
tonight oh okay oh it's my anniversary i
don't know when i'm gonna watch all this
stuff
oh just new york and and kardashians
like ben will kill me
okay whatever i have to we'd figure out
how to get screeners like yeah someone
hit us up
um okay so that is our show and yeah
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
morning on youtube monday through friday
so if you're watching this on video
this video on youtube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we are also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so it's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio
cast box and now we are also available
on amazon music podcast
so check that out and wherever you
listen to podcast find us the morning
toast and leave a five star review about
a beautiful stunning and smart we are we
love you guys so much we hope you have
an amazing day we'll see you tomorrow
for friday
[Music]
goodbye